Chemielehrer, 32, Single.
Das bist Du.
Die Experimente laufen super.
Doch du denkst nur an Lisa, …
die neue Englischlehrerin
an deiner Schule.
Sie ist wunderschön, witzig, klug, selbstbewusst ...
– und Single.
Kurz: Du bist unsterblich verliebt.
Leider aber ignoriert dich
deine Angebetete.
In einer schlaflosen Nacht hast du eine Idee.
Du könntest eine Liebespille herstellen, …
die ein Feuer der Liebe entfacht,
das nie wieder erlöscht.
Lisa hätte nur noch Augen für dich.
Du verbringst Wochen im Labor.
Bis du endlich
die Liebesformel gefunden hast.
Dann sitzt ihr euch zufällig gegenüber.
Da ergibt sich die Gelegenheit, Lisa die Pille unterzuschieben.
Du weisst: Ihr wärt für immer glücklich miteinander.
Was tust du?
Steckst du Lisa die Pille ins Törtchen?
Na Klar!
Du machst dich schön, um Lisa zu gefallen.
Die Liebespille ist nur ein anderes Mittel.
Oder soll Lisa sich frei für dich entscheiden?
Aber: Hast du dich frei für Lisa entschieden?
Die Liebe erwischt einen.
Sie ist keine freie Entscheidung.
Lisa sehnt sich auch nach grossen Gefühlen.
Sie würde die Pille wohl freiwillig nehmen.
Also: Was tust du?